[Music]
when we start today with the story that
caught us all by surprise we have
confirmed that Mariah Carey had
weight-loss surgery and that is not all
that we have found out when did Maria
have it done and why showing off her
already noticeable weight loss with me
days ago at her hand and foot print
ceremony
look I'm humbly I'm here I'm just like
I'm so happy this is a childhood dream
sources tell E team Mariah underwent
gastric sleeve surgery around six weeks
ago the procedure shrinks besides the
stomach so patients eat less our source
says at 47 years old Mariah is quote
feeling much better about herself this
is a new beginning for her Bryan rep
would not comment about any weight loss
surgery another eighty source says
Mariah had grown extremely insecure
about her fluctuating weight quote yet
the tags cut out of clothes so she could
be blissfully unaware of her size other
people want to be shady and and if they
want to be shady that's fine just
regarding haters 2et in the past over
the summer online trolls unkindly
targeted these unflattering photos from
her Caesars Palace presidency Ichi has
learned Mariah's planning on moving her
residency to the Venetian Hotel starting
in March of 2018
last year she told Carly just how much
she hate the dietary regimen leading up
to those types of shows try to bring the
moments the costumes but you know it's
hard though that's what's low on my
bleak day
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]